it is he a ginger in the ball area looks
like torment from game of love it me too
I have a theory I have my own I don't
know if we want to you know go down week
away you might as well drop it I'll give
you my really super condensed I think
okay I think Circe initially is gonna
win and I think that Jamie is gonna kill
his own sister and Jamie just gonna end
up taking it and he's gonna bring Tyrion
as his hand of the king cuz he knows he
needs Tyrians do you think Tyrians gonna
betray Daenerys they're gonna die
there's no happy endings here with John
and Danny know in a way we have to stand
when I get like really like excited I
stand yeah that was incredible theory so
what you're saying is is that Cersei
right Jamie's gonna kill his sister his
yes and that's why in the last episode
of this the last episode they had to
separate now when the two are making
love in the boat you know the dwarf
Kieran came out and there was a ominous
like you know it was a wide shot he was
deep into this right by the stairs
looking yep and you knew that there was
something going on I would say I did the
Brady Bunch with the tarantula coming
down the well and he walked away so
there's something going on with that guy
what's your theory what happens with the
White Walkers I think they're gonna be
destroyed ultimately and I think Dan
I think Danny's gonna die by her own
dragon the ice dragon because it's that
whole theme of kids taking over the
lineage from parents so I think her
child kills Danny yeah but the thing is
is that you that can't happen I'll tell
you why that can probably right it can't
happen because you know we know that
Game of Thrones has thrown things at us
that we're like like the wedding and
like you know what's-his-name dying in
the beginning of the first show Ned
Stark yeah Ned Stark dying I think the
North wind's
I think the Starks are at the top at the
I think between Kataria and and Sansa
mmm that's what I wanted nice that's
what I desire I don't think that's gonna
happen I think it's closer to maybe what
he's saying but I think that the Starks
somebody has to win I mean you're not
gonna go through Arya and the war what's
his name you know and all that all their
voyage and their point of view and all
that stuff right just to die at the end
you know I think there's gonna be some
work and going on I think I think you
know arias skills over being like you
know is the strongest one cuz if he can
warg into a dragon I think Brandon's
gonna kill the night king by probably
becoming him cuz he can time-travel yeah
then it'll make the whole full circle of
Jamie winning because he threw bran out
the window which got everything in
motion for him to become the white
Walker to kill those so that armies gone
and then Jamie can take the theory that
brand was the night king but that makes
it clearer how he would become a brand
is dressed in the last full season armor
he looks just like the night game yeah
okay so what you're saying is this so
you're recapping we just recap I know
how could I don't because I don't fully
you know when people talk no matter how
much I'm listening
am i I haven't done my up my brain it
takes a while right I need two passes
right so I need a clearing pass this is
Mike what I called the clearing behalf
okay all right and here's the clearing
pass so what you're saying to me is this
is that what's his name brand brand
brand is like the king
the main guy although I guess they do
have structurally the same kind of face
rank and trouble backward so he warps
into who the night hanging right how he
goes back in time I've never seen Brad
know I think I'm gonna take a step
further I don't think he worked I think
he threw whatever that that that osmosis
of time travel you know what his eyes
turn white and the longer he stays in
there it's not supposed to be good for
whatever your mentality what if by the
end his eyes are white and then they
just
slowly crystallize and turn blue because
he stayed in there too long and he
becomes the night king
[Music]